misunderstanding the things that we are
against women we kept them
because you can identify what is known
by necessity it's like tell me identify
who are you like where is the
sunrise what is women you know the
Western world is going crazy they don't
have enough now the point you have to
bring the Western World they cannot
really utilize this argument or this
doubt anymore about Islam oppressed
woman why I'm saying that because I
cannot Define what woman is
originally
man with his penis everything they tell
you he can be a woman too
it's crazy now understand that's why I
look what's happening a man raped two
women he told them he's a woman where
they did they put in prison with a woman
that's Paradise for him
slam woman with respect
about the wives
okay Allah mentioned about the believer
females if they are righteous they are
Paradise for them
our woman
to you to set our products in the stand
we don't put toothpaste next to it naked
woman
foreign
valuable than diamonds that's why in
which of countries there's there's
certain things you cannot insult a man
with don't insult his mother don't
insult his wife his sister his daughter
otherwise they'll be warm
you understand the way to work against
you you understand so we love our woman
if we hate women why we allow to marry
for
before a cup of coffee
for a cup of coffee I mean you love it
and we make sure that take care of them
you know another convention before he
died
he said take care of women